tick-tock has changed basically every
aspect of your life personal
private all of it but how has it
affected your dating life what the [ __ ]
is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the odd wax podcast
with your favorite sisters
sistine and sophia
i was the singer in the family and then
i do remember wait i just got a
flashback i remember i was taking
singing lessons and you came into the
gym
and you said sing for me and i said i
can't i'm not warmed up and you go prove
it all those singing lessons sing for me
you know what was so annoying though i
wanted to support and listen to you sing
but every time i would walk into your
room trying to catch you off guard when
i would hear you singing next door you
would always be like get out of my room
like you were so mean about it when i
was like only shower singers
just don't listen i'm good when i'm not
getting listened to and then right when
you walk in i have a voice crack or off
tune but i remember it was the first
time i thought okay i can do this i can
sing in front of sustain so i chose the
hardest song ever
it was you don't have to take your
clothes off to have a good time take her
clothes off with herself yeah i'm so
hard eddie literally looked at me after
i finished
like
you guys you know no i mean everyone
knows that feeling when you're watching
it could be like a little kid or someone
that tries to do something seriously and
they're just not that great at it and
you're like yeah
like you're getting like a sympathy nod
you're like wow this is the best part is
um you know when you're ever doing
something in front of someone and you're
nervous and you start laughing even
though no one's it's not because it's
funny but you're so nervous she's
laughing i'm laughing i think i told you
to turn around and stand in the corner
you made me stare at the wall like are
you so dramatic you know what though my
mom i had to turn the other way and
stare at the other wall
my mom always told us growing up know
your ability
so just because you can do something
doesn't mean you should can you sing no
but actually okay this is so funny that
we're talking about things that we're
not talented at that we thought we were
because this morning i was watching the
season finale of cheer on netflix season
two i was such a fan of the first season
it was like my quarantine binge with
jennifer
second season's a little sad
but i was shfitzing at the very last
episode stop seeing fishing in every
single would you like me to laugh like
five episodes what would you like me to
say instead of schvitzing
any other word in the dictionary
yeah
yeah excited nervous
so i was nervous sweating
at the last episode today because it was
the final competition winner takes all
the enemy teams going up against each
other and i was so invested actually i
didn't care about one single person in
the show i wasn't personally connected
to anyone but i was so nervous for them
that you know when your fingertips get
all like fuzzy and your body starts to
go a little tingly because you're
getting numb because you're you're
having an adrenaline rush or something i
was i was like oh my god
don't fall i was so nervous for these
kids and then i thought
oh my god sistine i've always wanted to
be a cheerleader that was like the one
thing that i wanted to do in high school
you could have
i couldn't have
why well okay i only wanted to do it
because i wanted to wear the outfit
instead of my uniform which i thought
was she wanted to be a character from
euphoria well okay it was so unfair so
we went to a really strict catholic high
school and the skirt length rule was
very much enforced four inches above the
knee but then if you were a cheerleader
you were allowed to wear the cutest
little oh yeah the most
short skirts yeah
shirts and they had these big bows and
it really was honest it kind of had the
euphoria look a little bit say i was
like it's like playing dress up to
school every day i know but i remember i
tried out for um i thought okay i can't
make the cheerleading team and so i
thought why don't i and sign up for the
interpretive dance time oh i remember
this
yeah do you know what can i explain one
thing i remember walking into her dance
room and they were making a bicycle out
of their bodies a lot of people a lot of
people say
i think it's the wheel
i gotta give i gotta give context so i
try out for it everyone i feel like most
dancers bodies they're really petite and
small even in height they're just short
i was easily seven inches above everyone
else yeah you're petite but you're very
long so i was not expecting to make the
team i can't touch my toes i can't jump
high in the air there's nothing graceful
about my body movements so for some
reason i made the team but i think the
teacher did that on purpose so that i
would be sort of the base for every
stunt
so all i did was hold the props hold the
girls yeah i was in the back of every it
was hard it was so embarrassing i
remember you were on the ground on your
back and your legs were pinched
yeah you were you were the pedals you
were the pedals i remember now i
remember walking i'm like what the hell
did she sign up for yeah but you
actually know we did gymnastics for a
hot second i remember that remember mom
used to drive an hour out of her way
every day like every kid did gymnastics
we were trying sistine
got offered to join the team
it took me five months to do a back bend
so
and they said they i asked like can i
join and they said no
but because i couldn't do it like
sistine was able to do
a front flip backflip but again it goes
back to jennifer's point of know your
ability she saw me out there and said
this ain't for you kids but she could
but that's right know your ability but
you but she told us yeah but that
doesn't mean that you couldn't do it you
were good at it like you couldn't good
yes sophia
you were on the balance beam you could
do all these stuff because i had big
do a cartwheel like i really you guys a
back bend walkover that's probably the
easiest thing you do when you're what 12
years old it took me six months to get
that and so i they blamed it on like my
uh well mom kept saying oh because you
had heart surgery it's probably the
tissue that's causing you to not be no
i'm just a very uncoordinated unbalanced
so yeah i was really jealous when she
got offered that but then he didn't take
it no i know when i have a kid i'm not
putting in anything that it's going to
be bad at it's got to be number one
mm-hmm i feel you're going to put your
kid in golf which i want to golf and um
maybe sly always said he wanted us to be
really good like a pool master at
playing pool you're kidding
yeah because that's cool you go to a bar
you're like how do i hold the stick you
know and you just wake up
just collect the money
you know that's kind of like that's your
dream yeah i could tell i don't
understand why people get tattoos of
their significant other names no shade
on people that do that but i just
that's a that's a commitment i actually
saw this tick tock the other day of this
guy
on his um on his side he had let's say
her name was like karen i don't know and
put karen in big letters and then
uh the next photo was
karen's name like
scratched out with a tattoo and then the
next photo was karen's name under the
scratched out version no and then the
next photo was the second chara name
scratched out and it was a continuous
thing until i'm not kidding his entire
side had at least
eight
carrots and scratch out cairns it was so
funny well our dad has a tattoo of mom's
face on his arm so imagine that i mean
like getting some weird tattoos lately
well i hate i i there's i like his uh
rose tattoos because that's for us so
wait i don't know
like so this is so funny so my mom told
him
do not get tattoos until you turn 60
because then you can just do whatever
you want with your body but you're going
to regret it and if you still want it at
that time
do it my mom mother is my dad yeah for
sure so he turns 60 and gets basically
two full sleeves his entire back yeah
and both of his pecs done
and he puts my mom's face
like massive on his shoulder
and so it looked really good in the
beginning and about 10 years later
he decided was aging and so was the
tattoo so is the tattoo so he decides to
touch up the face
he puts so much makeup makeup on my mom
so it's imagine like an older
faded face with like brand new makeup
it's like 70s makeup where whatever like
bright eyeshadows and the red red light
i look horrible it's so funny she looks
so ugly and then he got a giant scorpion
above his butt
and so it looks like it's coming out of
his ass justina it does i'm like what do
you do when he goes i just felt bored
today and got a scorpion i've always
said i think i would want to tattoo but
at the same time i hate needles and so i
think i'd faint during the session i
mean if you're going to get one it has
to be funny cece laughs at me because i
said i want a freckle of a tattoo so
then people think it's a freckle but
it's a tattoo
do you know what i'm saying so no i
don't just for myself to know i got
tattooed
go on a freckle yeah i see people trying
to get rid of those in here i like that
last time and you were laughing at me
no because people try to get rid of
freckles but you want to add a freckle
just no it's not for it's the
it's a joke but the purpose is basically
just to know i'm doing my shoe size i'm
putting my shoe size on the bottom of my
foot
so that when i go to a department store
i just have to lift my foot up and
and i'll put the european sizing on the
other one perfect i like that how about
that you show that to your boyfriend and
then he knows exactly what to get you
that's what i'm talking about exactly
this time should we
introduce our guest today yeah so we
have the really hilarious exciting
smart tick tocker victoria paris coming
on today and we've followed her for a
bit like she's blown up really i know if
you guys haven't already seen her on
your for you page because she is just
all over mine
she is
really funny witty i like her i don't
give a [ __ ] attitude so i think it's
gonna be really exciting to sort of get
her perspective on you know making a
career off of an online platform yeah
and this girl is definitely 100 real so
she's definitely 100 on wax so stay
tuned for victoria
[Music]
i have a new baby
you want to know its name yeah
athletic greens oh my gosh well you guys
i hope you're enjoying the episode so
far but sophia and i want to take a
quick moment to announce our very new
exciting sponsor athletic greens we are
partnering with them because it's a
product that we started using and loving
because we needed more energy athletic
greens doesn't taste like it's super
healthy because we don't like that
chalky greeny type of thing that's in a
lot of those products it has a kind of
mild tropical taste that you guys can
look forward to in the morning ooh
you guys you're gonna taste like you're
in hawaii why not so you're probably
asking what is this stuff with one
delicious scoop of athletic greens
you're absorbing are you ready
75
75 high quality vitamins minerals whole
food source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system energy focus
recovering aging it goes on and on and
on athletic greens is a lifestyle
friendly so whether you eat keto paleo
vegan dairy-free or gluten-free
and i don't know if this is important to
you but it's important to me it has less
than one gram of sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals or artificial flavoring of any
kind and it still tastes good it
supports better sleep quality and
recovery and also supports mental
clarity and alertness multivitamins are
so important for anyone to take tons of
people take some kind of multivitamin
and it's important to choose one with
high quality ingredients that your body
will actually absorb like athletic
greens athletic greens is a great
company focused on sustainability they
are climate neutral certified companies
in 2020 they purchase carbon credits
that support projects protecting old
growth rainforest and if that isn't
enough to get you guys already hooked on
this product for every purchase they
donate to organizations helping to get
nutritious food to kids in need
including no kid hungry here in the u.s
in 2020 athletic greens donated over 1.2
million meals to canada that's amazing
so right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
the convenient daily nutrition
especially during the times of flu and
cold season just one scoop with your
water every morning and that is it
there's no need for millions of
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health they make it so easy
so if you want to get in on this amazing
product athletic greens is going to give
you
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com
unwaxed again it's athleticgreens.com
unwaxed so take ownership of your health
and pick up the ultimate daily nutrition
insurance
you guys were so excited because this
week we have the hilarious victoria
parish she is a business savvy hilarious
tick tocker who grew her page from zero
to one million followers in six months
she's a cult following on youtube where
she always stays open and honest about
everything she has going on in her life
this is
victoria paris
yes thank you thank you thank you
um we are so excited to have you on i
have been seeing your videos all over my
4u page i mean i see your apartment
stuff you trying on outfits running
around new york i feel like i'm already
friends with you do a lot of people tell
you that when they watch your content
yeah i think that parasocial
relationships are real and i think that
the more you let people get to know you
the more they feel like ownership or
familiarity or like casualness with you
and that's definitely a big thing with
my content
i feel like that takes a lot of guts
because i know for me sometimes in the
beginning when we were doing this
podcast now it's easy i can just
talk [ __ ] on myself so much like i will
make fun of myself all the time and
people relate to that but in the
beginning it get kind of daunting but
were you always that person that could
just say you know screw it i am who i am
and whether you like it or not
you know
yeah i definitely think that it was
something i struggled with my whole life
was like not that like i faced like an
abs like an insane amount of like uh
adversity or stuff like that like i
always just i had a great upbringing and
i think that
no matter what i did i just always felt
like i stuck out like a sore thumb and i
think that um
through filming myself every day so much
that it just transfers really well
through the camera i mean that makes a
lot of sense because sometimes when you
do something like film yourself you
become more comfortable with looking at
yourself
so
i kind of want to backtrack so you said
you grew up in north carolina
and you went to indiana and then you now
end up in new york city at what point
did you start doing tick tock and what
did your life sort of look like before
tick tock even happened like what were
you doing for a job tell me about that
not good vibes um and then i transferred
to college in new york city where i um
originally my first year living in the
city i was working for a celebrity
stylist
and in school and then i realized that
you don't get paid any money in fashion
and i was barely eating and so broke
that i was like okay i'm gonna be a
personal trainer equinox now because i
love working out and they still didn't
pay me a lot of money and so
my parents were like you're about to
graduate you need to find a job that's
lucrative and you can support yourself
so i started working at a finance
startup and i really loved it um
everybody in my family works in finance
i
never saw myself working in it um
but i lost my job due to the pandemic
and i had always like
okay wait back up so i worked at this
finance startup and because i was
working in finance i just deleted all my
social media i had no social media for
like a year or so i wasn't gonna need it
i just was being epic me and i was like
i'm so different
um that but by the way that is different
i mean i don't know a lot of girls that
just completely go cold turkey for a
year right yeah yeah it made me severely
depressed it made me so sad really you
know that's the opposite of what people
say in reverse what you were saying
earlier is like you become more
comfortable with yourself when you film
like my perception of my own body and
the way i looked became so warped
because i wasn't getting like any
validation line of being people being
like love your outfit or like or like
swiping up on my story it just felt like
people forgot about me and i was like
living in the middle of new york city
basically like totally off the grid and
it just felt like i was isolating myself
basically it wasn't like
liberating me it was isolating and then
i started making videos about a year ago
and it just exploded and turned into
something massive okay well that is so
clever because i don't think i ever saw
anyone on the tick tock platform that
was sort of using it to promote their
d-pop because
as you may as well know like
one video off to tick tock can grow your
following so fast like i've never seen
it more than instagram more than
snapchat more than anything so you're
promoting your clothes and you said that
you worked for a stylist so you've
always sort of been into fashion and
you've always sort of had your niche but
was there ever like
an awkward fashion stage for you because
i know sophia and i for years grew up
with like heinous sense of style yeah
and then i feel like kind of now we're
starting to figure it out i'm 23 and
it's like getting there
did you always just have a really good
sense of style well i did do a deep dive
on your instagram and i definitely think
you got there like you are there it was
reciprocated right also wait we met
during fashion week correct we did yes
and i wanted to say that we met him in
that outfit
oh you did oh my god i felt like um a 14
year old in it i was wearing like a
dress i look like a doily but we met at
an allison olivia fashion show really
briefly during new york fashion week
um i
my
their
my mom
um i would say is like the biggest
inspiration behind my fashion she always
like dressed a little different and like
funky and as a kid she would literally
dress me up like a thotty like i got
thrown into elementary school so much
because she would send me to school in a
jean jacket with nothing underneath just
my titties out uh a short leather skirt
and knee-high boots and there's pictures
of me [ __ ] presenting in class with
like knee-high leather boots when i'm
like
eight seven eight that is iconic yeah
and she's like she was like my mom is a
whole interesting woman herself she was
never like
don't
wear that or don't do that she would
constantly be like be different try
something new like show up with no shirt
on like she was just a funny one who
needs a shirt for school anyway no
no free the nipple free the nipple
nipple i agree
that makes sense then why you do the
things you do and why you can be so
vulnerable and open about the way you
are on social media i mean i watched one
of your vlogs and you are you wake up
straight up in the morning showing your
entire day every angle and i lit
honestly like i can't do that sometimes
i'm like i look heinous in the morning
i'm like people are going to judge me do
you ever get people criticizing you or
anything like that like does ever phase
you or do you ever just feel like you
know what like i don't care
yeah i mean like at a certain point like
i kind of like leveled with it like if
you have a big nose you have a big nose
if you
have like one eyebrow that's shorter
than the other you know it so if
somebody comments that it's like i
already subconsciously knew that and the
way that i've been like perceived so
much online through like
hundreds of millions of views that
anything somebody could say doesn't
surprise me i already knew it about
myself and i'm already so hyper aware of
the way i look but because i film like
every angle and so often it's just like
you become
so intimately aware of the way your body
looks i have to agree with that because
i feel like tick tock more than any
other platform that i've been on the
comments are especially rude because
they're so clever and creative the way
that they insult you it's it's kind of
odd like i've been called
names in such a weird way that i was
like wait it hurt on a different level
and so i try my best to not read any
comments and i know people say never
look at the comments but it's really
hard not to when you're literally
posting a video of yourself and i mean
obviously you're going to want to see
what people are saying about it so
i guess this is a two-parter do you read
all of your comments and how has you
know joining tick-tock sort of changed
your personality are you more like sort
of you know shut down cold numb to it
all or do you are you the opposite of
that yeah um i
read everything i'm meticulous like i
every day like search myself on the
internet and on twitter and like
everything i read every comment
everything i'm tagged in because i think
that it's important to stay in front of
your image and to know how people are
perceiving you is to read the
information or like the uh conversations
out there about you and that is so
like that is so me being a masochist and
like just hurting myself over and over
and over but that's also why i think i
am
or was so successful in my come up was i
was reading all the data and figuring
out like what people like and um
yeah i was the most sensitive person
before any of this started i remember
like i had so many breakdowns in the
beginning and my friends are like you
will never be able to do this like you
will literally kill yourself if you keep
doing it like you can't handle it and
instead of like obviously
the that i like i was just so insecure
and now i'm just like emotionless like
totally like it's been a huge problem
even with my romantic relationships with
people being like i feel like you have
no emotions and you
are so like
and it's just because like
i totally get that because you could
bring that into your personal life
completely even with
you know friendships have you noticed
that
even girls and guys that are just trying
to be friends with you do you think that
people sort of use you now are you
feeling like you're not able to make
time for them or is it harder to connect
with them like what is your experience
we'll get into dating in a second
because i definitely want to get into
that but just making friendships how has
that been i mean i think that what what
was really um the friendships i had
before tick tock soured so badly because
of it like i've had really blackmail me
and like do all crazy [ __ ] and like try
to use me
and
and i think that the people who come up
in the tick tock scene and our tick
tockers are like quite literally built
different like when you start on youtube
or when you start on instagram there's
like this um
10 degrees of separation or whatever
where people feel like they're watching
you and you're a show or you're a
beautiful girl and so
they don't feel as entitled to you but
when people can tune into your life from
nine to five or nine to nine they feel
like they own you and they like right
the intimacy is what really is crazy
that is so interesting the fact that you
just said that they think that they own
you
and i was reading an article recently
that you or an interview that you'd done
and you said that you basically want to
use your tick tock to big brother your
life so you want 24 hours a day seven
days a week like updates all the time i
mean you were posting
how many videos a month like i was doing
like 20 or 30 a day
12 30 a day i mean do you ever just get
burnt out from it or do you just love
doing it recently i've curved down i
still post every single day sometimes
like five to ten but only keep like two
to three published because at a certain
point like it's quality over quantity
and before i was producing quantity over
quality
i don't think i got burnt out because i
remember like when i was in high school
in middle school i had like a thin stud
oh so you're totally used to it because
i know for me it's hard for me to
remember to post like a story like
sometimes i'm one of those people that
post one month
like once a month or something like that
it's just
so nervous to even post a tick tock i
just get it's stressful
oh god wait so you said you live in new
york right
yes how has that been because new york i
feel like a lot of my friends even they
said they have to have a hard shell when
they live in new york so you're doing
this and you're like
emotionless and now you're living in new
york how is living in new york do you
like it do you want to leave do you want
to stay
yeah i don't think i could i don't ever
imagine myself leaving new york but i
think that like as so i
started tic toc like around a year ago
and i was in this really small like one
bedroom flex apartment basically just
stuck in this one room and um then
people started like putting my address
out there and following my roommate to
the dog park and like posting videos
outside of where i lived so i had to
move and i was able to move into this
beautiful
massive space in tribeca because of tick
tock so you've been fully
stalked essentially oh yeah and people
have like released this address like it
just doesn't stop it's inevitable oh god
oh terrifying
i i don't even know what i would do if i
knew where people lit like where i lived
i mean that's like really invasive so i
did this giveaway and so many people
were like
like on the edge of their sheets waiting
for me like post where it was and like
following up to me posting where it was
girls were making videos of like
pictures of my apartment on streets
eating like i will wait outside your
house and follow you to like where you
put the actual ring like pictures of the
inside of my apartment and address and
everything and so that's like a threat
you know i'm five nine i work out every
day like i carry mace like pull up on me
i want you to like i would love to see
it
she's ready for it she's ready for it
like i'm a big [ __ ] like i that's the
only thing i find comforting is that i'm
actually like a tall woman and pretty
like athletic and but it's different
when it's like old men stalking you and
pulling up yeah well that's something
sophie and i struggle with because
oddly enough most of our following is
old men so you know i wish sort of we
had your demographic of younger females
but we have a lot of
creepy old foreign men that are writing
these uh
messages so it's not so cute i wish
honestly sometimes the girl was like
stalking me for a ring instead of like a
dead guy
but so
obviously tick-tock has changed
basically every aspect of your life
personal
private all of it but how has it
affected your dating life
yeah i think so when i first started
tick tock i was seeing somebody um from
right when i started so me and him
started seeing each other and i had like
10 000 followers on instagram and like
maybe like 100 000 on tick tock and i
was like
he doesn't know about it like he doesn't
need to know
like he's trying to use me and i was
like
and then he was with me until like i
think i had like 100k on instagram and
like half
or like a few hundred thousand on tick
tock and he very much knew about my
career at that point but he his family
was um
very famous in their own right and we
just had a bunch of crazy [ __ ] happen
when we were together where people were
showing up outside his house in
connecticut that i was staying at and
like taking videos of him oh my god and
he had his family
being famous themselves which i don't
think i'm famous i think of a tick
talker but his family was actually like
real famous and he was like i don't want
to go through this again i can't deal
with the stalking like we weren't even
like official and so it just added so
much strain to the relationship that we
ended
um
and then i was single for like two
months and then i found my ex-boyfriend
um and we were together for six months
and he was also a tick-tocker and that
was a very interesting experience
we gotta break this down yeah did you
guys meet on the platform or how did you
guys link up i had seen his videos on
tick tock but i had no clue who he was
and he makes videos of people so like
he's a he's uh he worked in animation he
writes children's books like he's a
producer um but then i was with my
friend one day and he was shooting a
video and my ex
jordan came
to to the set and we met there and i had
no clue who he was and i didn't even
know he was a tick-tocker
and then um we hung out like a week
later
and um he was going down to savannah
georgia to like work on his children's
book he was writing and i was like oh
can i come and he was like sure and so i
booked the bathroom you said that yeah
i'm very much like spontaneous you're so
bold
wait oh my god just to be like i want to
come with you
well but okay
i don't have that yeah i mean you've got
you've got balls in the best way
possible like how did you know that okay
what if you get to savannah georgia and
you're like oh wait i don't even like
this guy that much and i'm stuck in
georgia well we were like just there it
was just friendly for like the week we
were there but i think that i would have
kept myself busy no matter what like i'm
very like okay yeah like um and so we
got like separate rooms i went to
georgia within the next day and i
vlogged it all and it was like great
content um
and then we went back to the city and i
was like wait i think i really like this
guy and we started dating and we were
together
yeah
and you said it was the x now it's been
six months
yeah yeah how has it been since the
breakup i had decided two days before we
broke up that i was gonna daily vlog on
youtube like every single day every hour
of the day and this is like day two of
the daily vlog and i'm like holy [ __ ]
like we broke up shitty timing we had a
beautiful relationship like it was
amazing like we were still friends but
do you sometimes feel like maybe
you're like prioritizing work over a
relationship because i don't think
that's a bad thing but i guess it just
sort of depends on where everyone is at
in their life so right now are you
prioritizing work over your personal
relationship life yeah i think that the
nature of what i do is
like very volatile i wouldn't i'm not
going to say that i'm gonna do this for
10 years i plan to do this for five
years and do as much as i can in those
five years and like just go balls to the
wall and then retire or pivot or
whatever and so right now i'm totally
prioritizing my work because i don't
want to like
be one of those vloggers who's like hey
guys my wife just gave birth like this
is crazy we're buying a house like i
want to like you know it's crazy when it
goes that long
no it's smart you're using this as a
stepping stone for something else so
what would you love like your dream
stepping stone job what would that be i
would love post technology like do more
speaking um engagements i would love to
be a businesswoman who's behind multiple
brands be consulting be doing a lot of
charity work like organizing like
marathons and doing those and flipping
homes would be really fun like something
like that so just multiple hustles
always but just not necessarily centered
around social media no that makes sense
i feel like that's what
most people do especially i know that's
what we try to do i mean
we want to build this brand on wax to
something bigger but we wanted to get
behind a ton of different things that
not just revolve around podcasting
and i think that's really important that
he said because it does motivate people
to realize that it doesn't take
one year to become this big ceo you're
saying
commit to five years of heavy posting
and branding yourself and getting
yourself out there because that's the
point of work it's nothing comes
overnight i mean it's rare that people
can do that i feel is there any business
advice that you've gone that you've
really honed on to because it maybe
represents who you are or what you
believe in i think that at the end of
the day like it's all on you you are
developing the foundation and the
platform for everything that will be
built on top of it and i think that with
social media and like the accumulation
of followers that we get to this point
we're like cool i did it i'm done i
don't have to do much more but it's
constantly being involved in your
community and um
in your work and and employing the right
people right i mean i feel like you've
got your head on your shoulders
really right i mean
no one in your family like you said is
in the social media world so you haven't
exactly gotten advice of how to navigate
it from them but is there someone that's
sort of in the tick tock space that
you're like oh wait the way that they're
doing it is pretty clever
i'm gonna take a few pointers from them
no i think that there's like i think
that the tick tock space is like almost
worrisome to me of the way people
approach it and do it i think that
there's no i don't want to be like
there's nobody else out there doing what
i'm doing like but be like creators on
tik tok because it's so intimate you
can't compare the two
um there's no two that are alike but
there are a lot of people who make
similar content which is like the i'm a
new york city fashion student let's get
ready or like let's go for a run today
but my whole thing was doing everything
so
i think that it's hard to compare like
apples and oranges because they're just
not similar you know
for sure right i mean i personally
haven't seen anyone's content look like
yours because you're literally doing i
love watching you redo your apartment
that is so fun for me i mean you post
you getting botox you training for a
marathon i mean you do it all and it's
so fun what do you think is what do you
enjoy the most and what sort of content
gets the most
hate or backlash that you post
um i think that like the content that
gets the most hay um
it's crazy because it's not even like me
like getting dressed that gets a lot of
hate or like me getting botox he gets a
lot of hate it's like when i went on
colin and samir's podcast and i said
that um tiktok is extremely volatile
it's a high risk high reward app people
railed me like they tore me apart and
they're like this little girl what
saying tick-tock is so risky and it's so
hard like what the [ __ ] does she know
and it's just like when you try to speak
as a young woman with any conviction and
any business savvy
and you're not a man they'll be like
what do you know like if bryce hall or
josh richards
um tick tock is a is a very risky app
high risk high reward people will be
like legendary yeah you're so woke but
if you say it as a young woman it's like
shut the [ __ ] up
i
i feel like a lot of people though in
their workplace can relate to that exact
feeling
um
but again it's like i saw online there
was like a hashtag that people wrote
like victoria paris blocked me and it
got oh millions of views on that hashtag
and the first thing i thought was
um
a lot i think a lot of people were
wanting the attention of you personally
blocking them so that they would just
write extra mean things just so they'd
be like oh wait look she noticed me and
now i can be a part of the hashtag what
do you think uh sparked this and and why
do you think people
were sort of going out of their way to
just be cruel for no reason
i think that i am a huge believer in
like protecting your space and like your
mental health and it's like yeah i read
every comment i will see everything you
say but i won't allow you this face to
say it again like i read it the first
time that you think i'm ugly or
disgusting or you hate me that doesn't
mean you have the right or the the
liberty to comment it 10 million more
times i think that the block button was
created for a reason and when i started
making videos i was thinking about like
if i had a kid and they got in this app
and they thought it was cool to comment
that stuff like i would be so pissed and
so when you
control your comment section and you
curate it by blocking people restricting
certain comments you actually leave
space for a conversation and people were
like how dare she like what right does
she have but i'm actually leaving space
for a conversation on my own page if you
want to talk [ __ ] about me go make
videos on your own page and hashtag it
victoria paris blocked me like i don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah well it gives also you more
traction if people are even if they
didn't know who you are you're like oh
wait yeah who's victoria president
you're like okay i'm gonna check out her
page so it kind of
i mean it's yeah bowling in general for
saying like victoria paris blocked me
but now it's kind of a win for you
because it goes okay who who's this girl
like if they don't know who you are so
and i feel like people on this app
they're now getting more validation
especially on tech talk as christine
said
with the comments being just so rude and
people love it it's almost like the
meanest comments are the ones that show
up to the top because they get the most
likes and it's crazy that that's
the way it's structured and why people
are so normalizing this and it's i don't
know it's wrong it makes it harder to be
on social media all the time because i'm
the person too that reads everything
and i have those emotional breakdowns
i'm kind of waiting for the moment
where i'm uh
emotionally closed off from all of that
like you and i don't feel any of the
comments because
it does it does overwhelm you and i feel
like
i totally agree that it's important to
block the people that are really giving
you
a lot of [ __ ] for who you are and giving
space to people that love you and admire
you it's i mean i mean fine to do that
this is how i look at it if someone were
to write that comment and instead say it
to your face in person what do they
think the reaction would be if you said
what they're typing to your face i'm
gonna say [ __ ] off
like
it's the same thing i'm gonna block you
i don't understand i think people
honestly on the app as well are just
don't like to see another girl be super
confident
and not care that she's confident and
not really ha and maybe it doesn't look
like you're working at being confident
but that you're just inherently a
confident person
and i think that's
i see that on your page like you are
just yourself and people don't like that
when do you think you're going to
you ever think there's going to be
something that will like completely draw
the line and you're like i am done with
this platform i don't want to be on tick
tock anymore do you see that happening
i think that um
that's when they win you know when you
like exit and you're like i can't do
this anymore are you dating anyone
because i know for us
we try to avoid dating people that are
even in that famous realm of like tick
tock or anything like that just because
we don't want to get that speculation of
people saying like oh i had sex with her
because she's under the you know that we
don't even post our relationship yeah
because we get nervous about
stalkers
yeah just because of that so are you
fully single right now um i'm seeing
somebody right now um
yeah it's still like new and um like
trying to keep it more private because i
think that on the other side like i
don't worry about people seeing us
together i more so worry about the
development of the relationship which is
what happened in my last one it
developed totally in front of the camera
and i think that i thought it was a lot
more profound than it actually was
because the videos did so well
um so that's why i want to keep it more
private
and how do you feel like
being off the internet
has affected your relationship now is it
has it grown deeper has it been a lot
more vulnerable or has it just been
easier because i feel like sometimes
when you include
social media or even if we have too many
conversations about like her boyfriend
on the podcast there always can be this
thing where they go oh we shouldn't have
shared that or you shouldn't have been
doing that and that insecurity like now
they probably know
they you won't be doing that how has
that changed the relationship of a
person i am like i i demand respect so i
give respect um and so i wouldn't what i
fear is somebody um
not wanting to be seen with me on video
or not wanting to talk about them or
being embarrassed of me and that's
something that comes from childhood for
me but i more so worried because when i
would make videos with my ex they would
do so well and we would look so in love
that i thought the relationship was so
good when really it was just like we
weren't in love and we it really wasn't
that great but when things grow so many
views you convince yourself and you see
it you're like oh my god like we are
perfect together we are that perfect
insta couple like we look so [ __ ]
good and then you ignore all the actual
issues and so when i had this very
public breakup
i realized like am i upset that we broke
up or am i upset that i just lost a huge
piece of my content oh my god i know
because
in a way you you're wanting to put your
whole life on the camera you're doing it
for all you're following everything
you're not holding anything back so of
course why wouldn't you
you know share your relationship but
then again that is something that is so
hard to even have outside opinions about
and you're dealing with that as well
victoria you are
seriously a tough girl yeah you're a
badass yeah you honestly you are
and i want to come to new york and i
want to see your new apartment and i
won't stalk it i'll ask for the address
with permission
you're so cool we're definitely gonna
hang out why don't you plug where
everyone can find your tick tock your
instagram your handles everything
at victoria paris on everything
perfect
thank you guys so much for tuning in to
this week's episode of unwax podcast we
will see you next tuesday bye
[Music]
you